[موسيقى]
تسابق فرق الانقاذ المغربي الزمن لانقاذ
الطفل ريان ريان
من شتى البقاع الجغرافيه حول العالم امال
الملايين كانت منعقده على انجلاء ماساه
الطفل المغربي ريان اورام على امل ان تشهد
فصولها نهايه سعيده
او الحاجه كانت فكره يعني جميعا يعني ماشي
واحد نقطه
الاقرب الناس
عنده واحد البصمه واحد الذكرى في حياتنا
اللي عمرنا غادي ننساوها
عمرنا غادي نساوها
المهم
[موسيقى]
غاتبقى واحد بصمه حزينه
داخل ديالنا
ولكن بخير
[موسيقى]
كان الجميع موحدا على امل هو اخراج ريان
من ذلك البئر هذه اللحظات او الساعات التي
قضيتها داخل هذا الدفء الانساني الجميل
جدا والانسان العالمي يعني لم نكن نحس نحن
فقط كمغاربه متعلقون بذلك البئر بل كلما
نظرنا الى قنوات عربيه واجنبيه الا
وتاكدنا ان الانسانيه كلها يعني قلوبها
معنا وكانت دفء يعني يكون اكثر بهذه
المشاعر الانسانيه التي كانت تحيط بمكان
الذي سقط فيه ريان
قضت الامال نحبها بوفاه ريان يوم الخامس
من فبراير عام 2022
متاثرا بسقوطه في بئر مظلمه ليحيي اصحاب
الامال المنكسره ذكر امالهم
اما ذكرى ريان فربما لن يعاد احيائها
كونها لم تمت او تغب من الاساس عن وجدان
كل من سمع بقصته فاسر قلبه ووجدانه
[موسيقى]
في عصر يوم الاول من فبراير عام 2022
خرج ريان صاحب الخمسه اعوام من منزل اسرته
البسيط في قريه اغران باقليم شفشاون شمالي
المغرب
[موسيقى]
اصبح العالم اولا يعرف اسره او عائله طفل
ريان ويعرف دوار ريان ومنطقه اقليم شفشاون
عموما
كمئات الاطفال كان ريان يلهو في محيط
منزله لم يجل بخاطره البريء ان تتعثر
قدماه في فتحه بئر ابتلعته علق فيها على
عمق 32 مترا هي قرابه نصف العمق الى قاع
البئر الاقليم يسجل بين الفين والاخرى
حوادث مماثله لسقوط الاطفال في ابار في
ويديان من فوق الجدران ويتم انقاذهم يعني
بشكل عادي بعد تدخل السلطات كذلك ظننا ذلك
في سقوط الطفل ريان قلنا ربما سيتم انقاذه
ربما حوادث السقوط في البئر هي حوادث
قليله في العالم مثلا كنا سابقا نتحدث عن
طفلين او ثلاثه في العالم الذين سقطوا في
بئر
وثم بهم اعلاميا القصه تكررت هنا في
المغرب في شمال المغرب بالضبط في تمروت
عندما لاحظت اسره ريان اختفائه تبادر الى
اذهانهم انه ربما يكون قد اختطف مع
الساعات الاولى من صباح اليوم التالي
استطاعوا تمييز استغاثته من عمق 32 مترا
حيث انزلوا اليه في البئر كشافا وهاتفا
باحبال لتصويره والتحقق من حالته
[موسيقى]
بعد التاكد من سقوطه اخطرت اسره ريان
السلطات المحليه
فحرعت اليه قوات الدفاع المدني والهلال
الاحمر واجهزه الانقاذ
[موسيقى]
لا مش الصدفه هذه خدمه خدمه
اتصلوا بالاداره ديالي
وعيطوا لهم وعيطوا لي انا عيطوا لي ومشيت
مشيت
كنت خايفه
كنت مخلوع
[موسيقى]
الضحيه كل من عاش الحدث او تابعه او شاهده
هو يتالم حسب الدرجات
والشخص الذي يتعلم اكثر هو الضحيه الذي
عاش ليس الذي مات ولكن الذي عاش دائما
يحاول التقمص الام الضعيه كان شعور
غريب كما قلت شعور انك تحس بانسانيتك لانك
اب اب ليس فقط لابنائك في البيت ولكن اب
لكل طفل فوق هذه الارض انت تحس انك فعلا
انسان وان الموجودين والمحيطين بك هم بشر
وهناك روابط يجب ان تجمع هذه البشر ريان
علمنا في قصته
ان نكون بشر ان نكون انسانيين مع الجميع
ان يكون الحب
والنضال والكفاح من اجل هدف كان الهدف هو
اخراج ريان اخراج ذلك الطفل الذي وحد
البشريه وليس فقط المجتمعون في ذلك المكان
بالتزامن مع ملحمه انقاذ ريان صنع الراي
العام العربي والعالمي ملحمه تضامنيه
اشعلت شرارتها صفحه باب برد على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي فيسبوك التي يديرها عبد
المجيد احارز
كنحاول انقل يعني المعاناه ديال منطقه عبر
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وكنتوصل يعني من طرف الساكنه المحليه ديال
البوادي والقرى ديال الاقليم شفشاون باي
خبر جديد يتعلق باي حادثه
من بين هذا الاخبار اللي كانت بها هو خبر
سقوط الطفل ريان في ثقب مائي بدوار اغراض
جماعه مرود اقليم شفنا وقمت يعني بنشر
الخبر
يعني سويعات بعد سقوط الطفل في البئر ثم
يعني انتشر الخبر عبر مختلف المواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي الاخرى
كان ابن المنطقه منطقه باب برد الاب ديال
ريان والعائله ديالها يعني اصدقاء احنا
كابناء المنطقه
درسنا يعني درسنا مع بعضنا يعني ان نلتقي
يوميا يعني في السوق الاسبوعي في المقاهي
هاد الناس
كواحد من افراد العائله لاننا كما قلنا
احنا ابنائها منطقه واحده
من تدوينه صفحه باب برد التي يتابعها
حوالي 9000 مستخدم على فيسبوك تحولت
القضيه الى وسن انقذوا ريان الذي سجل
تغريده على موقع التدوينات القصيره تويتر
ليصبح الاعلى تداولا في المغرب والعالم
العربي
تفاجا بانتشار الخبر اولا على المستوى
الوطني حيث يعني تناقلته مختلف الجرائد
والقنوات العموميه المغربيه في اليوم يعني
في نفس اليوم انتقل الخبر الى يعني
اخبار عالميه
لما كنا ذاهبين الى المنطقه التي لم يسبق
انزلتها تبعد عن تطوان بحوالي ثلاث ساعات
في طرق صعبه للوصول الى عين المكان لما
وصلنا لم اكن اتوقع ان هذه التغطيه ستستمر
سته ايام وبالجنازه سبعه ايام كنت اتوقع
انها ست ساعات سبع ساعات كانت كافيه لذلك
لم ناخذ اي احتياطات كل الصعوبات
والعراقيل الميدانيه وضعف طبيب الانترنت
وضعف صبيب الكهرباء
واجهناها مهنيا فقط بالصبر والقدره على
التحمل
[موسيقى]
اهل تلك القريه طبعا
بدع وصل
تحملت عبئه الاف الناس في شحن هواتفهم في
ربما ان يوفر لهم المبيت والاكل ايضا من
بين التفاصيل هو معاناتنا من اجل ان يظل
هاتفنا مسحونا لننقل العالم ما يحدث
ان شاء الله
من فبراير من عام 2022
كانت غرف الاخبار منشغله باحتمالات
التصعيد العسكري بين روسيا واوكرانيا
والتوتر القائم بين الصين وتايوان لكن
ريان وهو ضعيف بين الحياه والموت في بئره
صرف غرف الاخبار عن طبول الحرب التي تقرع
شرقا
لتتصدر ماساته وجهود انقاذه عناوين الصحف
ونشرات الاخبار كما تصدرت اهتمام الراي
العام العربي
والعالمي انا اتواجد في موقع عمليات الجمع
على يميني هنالك تهريج ماء موجود لا نعرف
كيف سيجري استخدامه في عمليه الانقاذ
قبالتي ثلاثه انابيب معدنيه موضوعه
هنالك جرافه واحده تواصل الاشتغال انا
اراها جزئيا نتمنى من الله ان تبقى الامور
على حالها
دون ان يتعرض الفريق
لسقوط اتربه او ما شابه ذلك
[موسيقى]
اول كلمه ريان
باقي للذكرى من نهار اللي
شفت خبر وطرقته كنفكر تفاصيل ديالو الليل
ديالو المكالمات ديال القنوات العالميه في
الاربعه الصباح خمسه الصباح الاخبار
انتظروها كل دقيقه خصك خبر كيتصلوا بك
قنوات
يعني كل مرحله كل وقت صغير من ديك القصه
مازال في الدين ديالهم اظن مستحيل مستحيل
ينزول لان عشنا ليلا ونهار كنت كنعاس
الساعه كنقسم تولد ساعات اخبار جديده
القصه تدحرجت او يعني ككره الثلج فمن خبر
عادي في قريه نائيه هنا بشمال المغرب الى
قصه انسانيه العالم تحدث عنها يعني البئر
ما فيش الماء
والانسان واحد الحاجه
[موسيقى]
قد اغالي اذا قلت ان ريان معجزه انسانيه
فيها اخراج اسطوري
لولا الصحافه لما كانت اسطوره
ولولا طبيعه الحدث
لما كانت فيها رمسيه تتجاوز كل الحدود
كان لاخراج فيه سرا
وكان حدث ريان يتجاوز موت طفل الى حدث
انسان سوف تتذكره الاجيال
حجم التغطيه يعني لان وسائد الاجتماعيه
كانت في اليوم الاول ثم بعد ذلك المشعل
اخذته يعني مجموعه من وسائل الاعلام يعني
لعل العربيه كانت في بث شبه متصل حول
الموضوع في بث مباشر
على قنوات اخرى ثم انتقل الامر في اليوم
يعني في الاربعاء اعتقد في الاربعاء ليلا
انتقل الى الاعلام الدولي
حاله الانشغال العالمي بالطفل ريان كانت
اسطوريه كسر لم تكشف تفاصيله كاثر الفراشه
الذي لا يرى لكنه يولد سلسله من النتائج
المتتابعه محدثا في النهايه فارقا ربما في
ابعد البقاع من المعموره
ارجع البعض اثر ريان على الراي العام
العالمي ووسائل الاعلام الى حال اسرته
الفقيره او قريته المهمشه كما ارجعه البعض
لشجاعه الطفل التي ابت ان تستسلم للموت
بسهوله
الى السادسه صباحا شعرت ببرد قارص في تلك
اللحظه وانا ليست لي ملابس تقييم من البرد
فحتى حتى يعني
من سياره الزملاء او لم اجد اي مكان التجئ
فيه وقايه من البرد فبدات اكتشف من البنك
بشكل شديد جدا حتى خفت ان اسقط مغمى عليه
في تلك اللحظات كانت
تفكيري في التفعيان كيف انه تحمل كل هذه
الخمسه ايام وكيف ان اسرته تحملت تلك
ماساويه الانتظار
فدفعني ذلك الى ان اصمد اكثر اخرين
واحد الطفل
ماشي السن ديالو كان سبحان الله يعني واحد
الطفله
المهم ماشي بحال بحال الاخرين
بحكم انا عايشه تما ولا يعني عشت معها شي
طفوله ولا هذيك ولكن الحكم
يعني مميز على الاخرين
الامال تعلقت في البدايه بمتطوع الهلال
الاحمر المغربي عماد فهمي الذي استقرت
الخطه الاولى على انزاله باستخدام الاحبال
الانتشار الطفل والصعود به
[موسيقى]
كل شيء موجود ولكن
درست السلطات المغربيه توسيع البئر لتفادي
العوائق التي اصطدم بها فهمي ولتجنب ما
اصابه من اختناق الا ان الخوف من طبيعه
التربه الرمليه الهشه ووقوع الانهيارات
على ريان العالق في البئر الديائل وادي
تلك الخطه في مهدها ليبدا السيناريو
الثالث والاخير للانقاذ وهو حفر ممر راسيا
يليه حفر فرق الانقاذ يدويا لممر افقي
لانتشال ريان
[موسيقى]
تذكروا ليله الخميس لما كان المسار هو
الحفر عليه وبعد ذلك انقلبت الامور وبدا
الحفر في محيط
يعني الحفره فاستغرق الامر تقريبا اكثر من
24 ساعه وتابعناها يعني بتلك الطريقه ديال
التوسعه التي تمت يعني ان قلبت الامور
وما الليله تتذكر جيدا هي كانت ليله
الخميس تقريبا في الساعه الثانيه كنا
ننتظر ان يصل اليه لكن انقلبت الامور
فعشنا يعني توترا اخر ابنائي يدرسون في
جامعه في اسبانيا وما يؤكد هو كذلك اهتمام
الاسبان والطلب الاسباني بهذا الموضوع
عائله ريان كانت مصدومه غير قادر على
التركيز معنا لتعطينا المعلومات هذا النوع
من القصص تختلط فيه المشاعر تختلط فيه
المعلومات تشح في بعض اللحظات المعلومات
كنا نمر بساعات طويله من البياض
والانتظار ونحن على بعد امطار يعني امتار
قليله من مكان تواجد الطفل ريان بين هذه
الجبال
بخلاف المرابطين حول مكان الحادث رابط
الملايين امام شاشات التلفزيون والهواتف
يتابعون التطور قصه ريان كل دقيقه
[موسيقى]
في اسبانيا لانك الحدود مغلقه
يعني وقعت الفاجعه انقلبت الدنيا فعشنت
تقريبا خمسه او سته ايام لا نخرج من
المنزل رغم ان الابناء كانوا الدراسه
ديالهم ولكن تقريبا انا اعتكفت في المنزل
اتابع سواء القنوات وكذلك اتابع مصادري
لانني انا صحفي اعتمد كذلك المصادر واشتغل
[موسيقى]
كل الذين حضروا في عين المكان لا يختلفون
على الذين يستيقظون في الساعه الثانيه
عشره ليلا لكي يتابعوا ريان لان كل قنوات
العالم كانت مشدوهه الى الحفره الى البئر
الذي سقط فيه ريان كل العالم حتى رؤساء
الدول استيقظوا ليلا ليتابعوا الحدث
خارج البئر الضيقه والمغرب باسره
تشبثت عيون الملايين بالامل الذي كان خيطا
يوحدهم ويصل بينهم وبين الطفل كانت تتواتر
بين الفين والاخرى منبعا امكانيه وفاته
وكانت هناك شروحات علميه علميه بانه يعني
90% او كذا ربما انه يكون فارق الحياه
ولكن لم نكن لها لم نكن نهتم لها وكنا
دائما نحاول ما امكن
ان يستمر ذلك الامل الى اخر ثانيه كما
لاحظ الجميع الى اخر ثانيه كنا نحمل هذا
الامل
[موسيقى]
اكثر ما جعل هذه القصه ملهمه هو تجمع
هؤلاء الناس هو ذلك
الانسان الذي كان يحيط بمكان البحث عن
الطفل ريان هذا ما جعل هذه القصه يعني
مختلفه عن باقي القصص التي يمكن ان نغطيها
بشكل عادي يعني مهنيا بشكل عادي لكن قصه
الطفل ريان لم نكن نشتغل فقط بالحس المهني
بل كان الحس الانساني هو الطاغي ايضا في
عملنا حتى نحن كصحفيين هناك كان بامكاننا
ان نذهب بدورنا وننبش التراب بحثا عن طفل
ريان لان عندما كنا هناك وكانت فرق
الانقاذ تعمل كنا متعلقين بامل ان تتم يتم
اخراجه على قيد الحياه
[موسيقى]
بين جدران المنازل سواء من شاشات
التلفزيون او من مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
استعاده الاسر المغربيه والعربيه وحدتها
مره اخرى
فجميع افراد الاسره الواحده يجتمعون على
هدف واحد
يواسي كل منهم الاخر
[موسيقى]
خاصه الاباء ربما ما عرفتش كيفاش نظر
اليها يعني العزاب او كذا لكن اعتقد انه
كل الاباء نظروا الى ريان وعاشوا ذيك
الاحاسيس الى غير ذلك مع ريان كانه ابنه
انصح شخصيا كنت في هذا يعني
تقريبا بهذا الشكل لو ان هذاك الابن ديالي
لو كانت تعتقد ان ربط ربما كانت رباطات
جاش الاسره ربما التضامن يعني كان لصالحه
انا اعتقد انني كنت ربما نرتمي في الحفره
محاوله استخراج مثلا
الابن الى غير ذلك يعني انه فعلا كان
الامر صعب صعب جدا فيما يخص
كيفاش تصور او كيفاش الارتباط العاطفي
صراحه
انا كنت انظر ريال كانه ابني لا قدر الله
اذا ما حدث له مثل هذا الامر
طبيعه الحال اي انسان كان متزوج او غير
متزوج غيث بان الطفل ولكن انا كنت ابكي
دمعا عندما اشاهد اي لقطه لام الطفل ريان
واضع نفسي مكانها اكثر من الاب يمر الاب
وكان يعطي تصريحاته ولكن عندما تصريح الام
احس شيء غريب في قلبي وكنت ابكي كلما اعطت
ام او مرت عبر الكاميرا اظهر نفسها فيها
والضغط اللي عليها السيده هذيك الله
صراحه ماثر تاثر في الانسان
اعترف انني في بعض الاحيان كنت اختلي
بنفسي وابكي لانني اب وكنت اتذكر
دائما قصه الطفل ريان طيله هذه السنه
وتمنيت الا يسقط طفل في المغرب او في اي
مكان في العالم لان القصه كانت لها كلفه
نفسيه وعصبيه وصحيه لا ازال اعاني من
تداعياتها ولكن العمل الصحفي المهني يعطي
للانسان مناعه
[موسيقى]
علمي كبير
هذا التضامن الانساني الذي فيه نوع من
الرافه نوع من
الهشاشه الانسانيه لان تخيل ومعاشي الالم
يوحي بنوع من تقمص الضحيه وفي علم النفس
المرضي هناك عرض من الاعراض المعروفه التي
تسمى بعرض ستوكهولم وهو ما يسمى
التماهي للضحيه كل واحد يتخيل انه هو ريان
وانه هو الذي يعاني وانه هو الذي يشد
العلم اليه
فقصه التماهي هذه السيروره او خاصيه نفسيه
نتقمص الضحيه في الامها لذلك كان العالم
حاضرا ومشدوها اما بالحضور الذات الفعل او
عن طريق المتابعه من خلف القنوات
التلفزيونيه
تعاطف الكثيرون عندما استحضروا معاناه
ريان والامه واخرون تعاطفوا لحال اسرته او
للصموده امام الموت او للامال التي وحدت
الملايين
لتمضي الساعات بطيئه حتى مساء اليوم
الخامس من فبراير عندما انتهت قوات
الانقاذ من حفر نفقين الراسي والافقي
المؤديين الى ريان حيث عثروا عليه
لكنه كان قد فارق الحياه
يوم لطفل في اسبانيا حيدر في افغانستان
ولكن ريان تكلم عنها الصغير والكبير
مقاهي في اوروبا يتكلمون ويشاهدون
وينتظرون خروج الطفل ريان كان شيئا سهل
وصعب ومستحيل انك تنسى هذه القصه
[موسيقى]
الحديث عن قصه المرحوم ريان تعتبر في
تقدير الخاص تكريما له
وتكريما لكل الاطفال الذين قضوا نحبهم في
مثل هذه الاحداث المؤلمه
الذكرى الذكرى في القلب ديالنا
كل شيء
[موسيقى]